52 BENCH POINTS FOR THE
PELICANS.
THAT'S NOT A BENCH POINT BUT
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT POINT.
FOR THEIR SCORING STAR BRANDON
INGRAM.
THAT'S THE FIRST FREE THROW.
OUT COMES GRAHAM.
OUT COMES VALANCIUNAS.
IN COME CLARK AND TEMPLE.
WILLIE GREEN WITH WHAT APPEARS
DEFENSIVE SUBSTITUTIONS.
INGRAM THIS TIME MAKES THEM
BOTH.
IT'S 109-98, NEW ORLEANS.
PISTONS WITH THE 15-POINT THIRD
QUARTER LEAD.
FRANK JACKSON, SWATTED BY INGRA
ON THE SCOOP.
>> Greg: THERE IS GOING TO BE A
TECHNICAL FOUL ON THE PELICANS
BECAUSE THEY JUST DID SOMETHING
TRULY FOOLISH.
YOU'LL SEE IT.
THIS IS THE BLOCK SHOT BY
INGRAM.
WATCH WHAT HE DOES.
JUST WATCH THIS, OKAY?
HE GETS DOWN IN FRANK JACKSON'S
FACE LIKE HE'S GOING TO HELP HI
UP.
BUT THEN HE SCREAMS IN HIS FACE
IN FRONT OF THE OFFICIAL.
>> George: A TAUNTING TECHNICAL
ON INGRAM.
FRANK JACKSON MAKES A TECHNICAL
FOUL FREE THROW.
HE'LL GET A BETTER LOOK AT IT.